and you never asked your parents can i
take lessons
i i did i took them for a little while
but then
i just wasn't that disciplined uh i
then i learned bar chords and that was
it then i get like i don't i don't need
this
yeah yeah yeah were any of your um
family members or your mom and dad like
musical
um my my
father uh played
you know the same song
all the time what song was that i don't
even know oh
don't know but it was uh that's a
filipino song it's a filipino thing
on the organ on the oregon all right
yeah it was beautiful
right take a guess gilbert take a guess
a lot of filipino dads know edelweiss
that's a german song
wow that's good thank you i thought you
were going to say like freddie aguilar
like
probably that's what a lot of people do
yeah
so um and my grandfather was played
piano
too oh so if there is there's always
that like when my dad
people go well he was strict what not
but my dad and if you met my mom
my mom is very funny but not just
accidentally funny
she's purposely funny in terms of timing
and stuff so i just feel like it comes
more from her but my dad would do real
clever fart jokes
what's a clever fart joke just like when
you're sleeping
you know i never thought you know when
you fart on somebody
they're usually generally awake uh-huh
yeah i mean but like my dad would
and you he would you know maybe fathers
would fart on
their children through the underwear and
pants
my dad would pull it down bare acid yeah
yeah so you get
debris the not just debris but the block
the way
the way it went the wind you could it's
you know
you could feel it right so and then you
would go ah
i got you you know i mean that kind of
your thing so i learned that kind of
comedy from him
but the timing from my mom right but i
don't
you know it comes from somewhere i also
think that
filipinos have said this before
filipinos and
koreans are similar when it comes to
comedy humor because look at the
funniest
i mean i don't want to get in trouble
here because i know the climate we're
[ __ ] in
right but this i'm just throwing up
factual things
for a while it was just in the comedy
scene it was generally
filipino dudes and korean people
you know and you would see maybe one
japanese person or one chinese
descendant person
but generally you could rattle off 20
korean comics and 20
filipino comics in the scene i just
think it has to do with
culture you know yeah or it's very
similar
so when you i want to go back now to the
pixies so when you
were with charles how did love ring
what's his name
dave lovering that's what i said